ça va être un hiver excessivement
difficile parce qu'on lutte contre trois
virus les nouvelles du ministre
québécois de la santé sont peu
réjouissantes les urgences pédiatriques
débordent et pas de répit
à l'Hôpital Sainte-Justine 300 enfants
sont admis par jour le double de la
capacité d'accueil mon fils il fait une
pneumonie et puis c'est un peu sévère ça
fait depuis hier que on attend d'avoir
une chambre mais où est donc la santé
publique pour conseiller la population
en matière de prévention demande une
médecin de Sainte Justine sa collègue
est d'accord le message des autorités
doit être plus clair ce qui m'inquiète
c'est que les gens s'isolent plus quand
ils sont malades en général donc j'ai
beaucoup de gens qui se promènent avec
mal de gorge le nez qui coule des rhumes
sans porter le masque vous avez des
symptômes vous portez un masque pour
l'instant la santé publique demande au
Québec d'user de leur bon sens le
docteur Luc boilou recommande le masque
dans les lieux publics pour les plus à
risque ou pour ceux qui ont les
symptômes d'un virus respiratoire en
Ontario des chirurgies pour enfants sont
repoussés de nouveaux lits en soins
intensifs sont ouverts
des discussions sur la réintroduction du
masque dans les lieux publics on court
et le médecin eugéniste en chef fera une
annonce lundi matin pour sa part le
gouvernement fédéral insiste sur la
vaccination contre la covid 19 et la
grippe ce qu'il faut faire preuve de
plus dans si on veut aider nos
travailleurs de la santé après soin des
gens qui en ont le plus besoin il faut
individuellement selon ces experts faire
attention se faire vacciner c'est la
base mais contrairement aux deux
dernières années à l'approche des fêtes
les gouvernements semblent tout de même
peu enclin à réintroduire des
restrictions ici Charles Dumoulin
Radio-Canada Montréal